ti rival avocats spécialistes du
numérique
bonjour merci d'être avec nous thierry
vallat alors ce changement de cap des
états unis donc vers un accord
international sur la taxation des géants
du numérique aspect c'est un pas
réellement en avant est ce que on peut
parler d'une réelle avancée on
l'attendait depuis depuis plus de dix
ans on est véritablement dans
aujourd'hui une très très bonne nouvelle
pour combler cette faille béante qu'il y
avait dans la fiscalité internationale
concernant la fiscalité des gaffes et
les atermoiements récent avec
l'administration trump sont aujourd'hui
apparemment levé par l'abandon de ces
clauses de refuge à la clause de ses
phares bord qui normalement était
annoncé comme abandonnée par la
secrétaire d'état au trésor yale m donc
oui c'est une excellente nouvelle parce
que ça va faire rentrer beaucoup
d'argent normalement dans les caisses
européennes alors sans les concours de
l'accord qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous
dire alors les contours de la corne le
sait qu'on ne le connaît pas encore
puisque alors je rappelle qu'il est fait
sous le sous l'égide de l'osce et d eux
normalement donc ça devrait être conclue
d'ici d'ici l'été
a priori donc on a encore deux gros
points à discuter par rapport à par
rapport à cette taxe c'est est-ce que
combien combien ça va ça va rapporter
aux différents pays qu'elle est que le
taux le taux une minimum pour pour
chaque pays
et puis la répartition entre le de ce
qu'on appelle le but pays de
consommation et pays production donc si
les deux piliers qui sont aujourd'hui en
discussion mais globalement on considère
que ça va rapporter 100 milliards de
dollars
donc on s'est vraiment est énorme et
pour la france notamment
c'est d'après les prévisions ça pourrait
rapporter entre 5 et 7 milliards de
dollars donc c'est extrêmement important
et puis le corollaire c'est que ça
empêcherait les les états création de
produits français qui avait été la
sanction prévue par l'administration
trump en rétention de l'ataxie gafa donc
oui ça serait vraiment tout bénéfice
pour pour les pays européens dont la
france donc il
tim taxation par rapport aux gaffes à
qui rappelons le sont comme les grands
bénéficiaires de la tat de la pandémie
due qu'aux vide et qui se sont jamais
été inventé le terme de gaver mais en
tout cas qui ont énormément progressé au
niveau des chiffres de leur chiffre
d'affaires en nombre ces derniers mois
grâce
on va le dire à la pandémie à vous
parler de la france justement c'est une
victoire hausse et pourra pour la france
vous l'avez dit qu'ils avaient été
sanctionnés financièrement on le
rappelle il ya quelques mois sous la
présidence de donald trump pour avoir
justement instauré une taxe qui
s'appliquerait aux géants technologiques
américains
oui et bruno le maire n'a pas été avare
d'efforts pour justement mener à bien
ces négociations ça a été le leader
européen depuis deux 2 plusieurs années
maintenant ils se il se démène
véritablement pour pour aboutir à
trouver un accord aujourd'hui ces
efforts sont couronnés ont peu emballant
féliciter parce qu'il était un peu il
fait un peu cavalier seul il était un
peu seul contre tous qui n'a pas été
beaucoup aidé là manifestement c'est le
couronnement d'une oeuvre d'une d'une
action qui va permettre quand même
d'être très très significative dans les
luttes contrôle c'est l'évasion fiscale
que les gars femme avait
systématiquement saleh depuis depuis de
nombreuses années en rouge rappelle fia
beckham depuis 2010 ce qu'on est et
condé dans la structure de l'accord
alors pour les gaffes à qu'est ce que
cela signifie cet accord d'abord comment
est ce qu'elles perçoivent ce changement
de cap de la part des états unis
on n'a pas encore les réactions par
rapport à par rapport aux déclarations
donc ils sont tout toute récente de
s'arrêter au trésor bon pour eux la
sanction c'est enfin c'est c'est payer
plus d'impôts de toute façon il était
maintenant systématiquement contrôler et
taxer par les différents pays européens
je rappelle qu'il ya eu facebook
notamment google d'énormes sanctions
fiscales qui ont été sans qui les ont
sanctionné et qui ont été débattus par
des redressements fiscaux et négocier
ensuite par les différents gaza donc ils
vont payer davantage d'impôts par
ailleurs
l'earl avantage pour eux c'est comme en
a un aura quelque chose de clair et très
franchement la fiscalité de qui va leur
être imposée n'est qu'une petite goutte
d'eau par rapport aux profits faramineux
qui sont quels sont tous en train de
faire donc grosso modo j'allais presque
dire s'il est gagnant gagnant pour tout
le monde y compris pour les gaza qui
n'ont pas qu'ils ne tiendront pas grand
chose en tout cas une goutte une goutte
d'eau par rapport à leurs gigantesques
profits
vous précisez justement j'avais demandé
les répercussions pour les gars femmes
et pour les consommateurs est ce qu'il y
aura des répercussions pour les
consommateurs je pense qu'il n'y aura
pas de répercussions alors à moins que
les que amazon et les compagnies
augmentent leur leurs commissions
maintenant pour répercuter est répercuté
les incidences fiscales
je ne je n'y crois pas trop je pense que
ça sera assez neutre et en revanche ça
ça permettra aux caisses de l'état et
donc aux consommateurs in fine et de
pouvoir récupérer de pas mal de pas mal
d'argent donc et puis c'est tout à fait
on va dire équitable même si ce terme
est toujours un peu galvaudé dans
matière fiscale en l'occurrence je pense
que ce sera tout à fait légitime que une
véritable imposition normale puisse
puisse être appliquée en toute
transparence par rapport à ces à ces
genres de numérique et on peut espérer
un accord d'ici à l'été
d'ici l'été est normalement c'est prévu
sinon bah on essaiera de faire en
bilatéral mais mais normalement je je je
pense que maintenant il ya le bon bout
et les trois quatre mois qui viennent
seront décisifs mais je crois qu'on a
fait le plus dur avec cet abandon de la
la clause de césar bord merci beaucoup
ont tiré valin d'avoir répondu en direct
à vos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes avocat spécialiste du numérique 1